- [Interviewer] Alright, Ann.
Welcome back.
- Hi.
- [Interviewer] So the
last time you were here
you told me about what happened to you.
Was that on Figueroa?
- No, well, I left from Figueroa,
but it didn't happen on Figueroa.
- [Interviewer] You're on another street
or were you even on the street?
- I was looking to another
street, I told you,
I left with a friend that I trusted.
- [Interviewer] You got
beaten up and all kinds
of crazy stuff for like three days.
- Yes, that, well, I left
with a friend from Figueroa,
and we ended up somewhere else.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
it's a horrible story.
So what's going on in your
life since, since then?
- I'm just taking it one day at a time
and I'm trying to catch
up with everything.
I finally caught up with my rent for
as my living situation.
So now, you know, instead of
owing them, so many hundreds,
I'm back to pay at $80 a day
which is hard because it's like,
once you pay the 80 dollars,
you only get a few hours out of a day.
If you relax and then you
you have to be right back
out there to do it again,
and again, and again,
you know what I'm saying?
And it's really, it takes a
toll on you, it really does.
- [Interviewer] So are you still working?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] The same way you were?
- I have no choice.
- [Interviewer] You have no choice.
- I have to.
I mean I don't want to be homeless
in the streets, you know,
or nothing like that.
You know, I'm still trying
to build everything back up.
Everything is still
pretty, basically hard.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like
you succeed one day
and you get like maybe, maybe an hour,
maybe two to feel good because
you did this or whatever.
But in reality, you're
just, it's never ending.
It's never ending because
you got me every single day.
You have to deal with this.
You know, a lot of times lately
I've been sleeping a lot.
It's like I do what I
have to do to survive
but I just, you know, I'm tired.
- [Interviewer] But you're living,
like, it sounds like day by day?
- Day by day, hour by
hour, minute by minute,
second by second.
It's like being in the middle
of the ocean and you try to
swim to the shore to get out,
but these waves are
steady pushing you back
and you're not able to get to
that shore, you right there,
but you get this wave.
It's going to push you back so many feet
and then you got to swim harder
and harder and harder to try to make it.
And you're so tired, you know,
you feel like it's just going to end.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just, that's how it feels.
You know, basically that's how it is.
- [Interviewer] And has it
been harder to do this kind
of work since what happened to you?
- Yeah, yeah.
You know I have to pray a lot
and I have to just hold my
head up and it was like, okay,
we're going to get through
this day who want to do this?
And you know what I'm saying?
It's like, but I'm
paranoid all the time now.
I'm very much afraid
because it's like every car that I get in,
it's like, is this person
going to try to hurt me?
Is this person going to
try to do something to me?
You know, it's really, really scary now,
you know what I'm saying?
But I still got to do what
I gotta do to survive.
You know, you know, it was kinda,
Only thing I did different this time.
Okay I talked to a friend
of mine and she works also.
So she told me about
a school and it's UEI.
You know, because I had went to school,
I wanted to go to school,
maybe Jack will help change
and everything like that
I did the whole application
everything talked to people online.
And then we got to the financial aid part.
They said that my student loans and stuff.
So all of a sudden, everything
just stopped right there.
And it oh, well, if you get this,
once you get this part taken care
of everything like
that, they call me back.
They just cut my whole application off.
And that right there
just took a toll on me
because it was like,
wow, for real, you know.
So I've been kinda I would say
doubtful now because I
tried to take another turn,
do something positive,
and I got shut down on that.
So it's like, I feel like,
you know, none of them,
I just had a birthday
and everything is just, it's just life.
I fucked up life.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, hope is
an important thing to have.
And you get that kind of, yeah.
- I tried to tell myself
okay you can do something
about this situation
with the financial aid.
Maybe you could still go to school.
You know what I'm saying?
And it seem to me everything
in his world revolve
around money, money, money, money,
and materialistic things.
And that just really fucks me up.
It bothers me.
It really does because it's like
no matter what you're doing, you know,
more money you see the
more problems you have
you know what I'm saying?
You can't get forward.
That's why so many girls we can't get out
of this situation because we
got everyday things going on.
You know if you're trying to live a life
and you have no other choice,
you know, what can you do?
- [Interviewer] There are
less expensive places to live
in California.
- No, no, I, the lesson, the
lesson, I don't see that.
- [Interviewer] You're from Texas, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Moving back
to Texas must be cheaper.
- I can't.
And I'm embarrassed to say,
but I got kicked out of the state of Texas
when I was younger.
So I can't go back to Texas.
- [Interviewer] You can't go back?
- No so it's like where I stay right now,
I'm really comfortable.
You know?
'Cause when I'm inside my place,
I'm in my own world and I
don't really realize where
I'm at unless I open my door
and go outside that it's
like, you know, it's like--
- [Interviewer] Is it a new
place or the same place?
- The same place.
- [Interviewer] Oh you got
it back because it sounded
like they were kicking
you out or something.
- Well, yeah, they kept locking me out.
I've been locked out so many times
I think that's what made me
stronger because you know
like I said, when I got
back lock on, you know,
lock on my door and everything
like that and it's like,
oh my God, this is crazy.
You know what I'm saying?
And as much as I try to give him this,
try and give him that, and I'm still in,
then at the end of the day
they say I still get locked
out because I don't want, you know--
- [Interviewer] You got some
nice help from my viewers,
right?
You got some nice help from my viewers?
- Oh my God.
I'm totally shocked.
Totally shocked right now.
- [Interviewer] I think a lot of females
really related to your story.
- That makes me feel
good and I'm a cry baby.
Excuse me.
But I want to thank everybody
for caring and donation
whatever I totally didn't
expect none of this,
especially Juliet, thank you, much love.
I appreciate it.
You know, it helps a whole lot.
I can get shoes now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, no,
but it must make you feel good too,
that somebody cares out there, right?
- Yes, it's so scary.
It's like seriously, because
I didn't expect none of this.
None of it.
And I'm like, really just appreciative.
- [Interviewer] Have you
shared this story with anybody?
Like on set?
- No I haven't even seen it myself.
No I was totally embarrassed--
- [Interviewer] With
your friends and stuff.
You don't really?
- No, I walked up on a friend of mine,
she said I'm looking at
your story right now,
I said, no, don't do that.
Don't look at it.
You know?
And she was like, it's okay.
I was like, no, you know,
no, I haven't looked at it.
- [Interviewer] To go through this
because there's shame involved too, right?
- A lot.
- [Interviewer] I mean you're
not to blame for it, but--
- We all go through a lot.
But a lot of things I've been through
is just hard to talk
about and tell about it.
And people close to me and
people, you know what I'm saying?
That I share, you know, a life with,
for the streets and everything.
'Cause people in the streets
we're all street family we're really
like family because we all out here
in the streets going
through the same thing.
So we have nobody to depend
on other than ourselves.
And we kind of like
look out for each other.
Like my special friend that, you know,
came to me and told me that about the,
you know, situation, the donation.
I was like, seriously.
I was like, oh my God, I can't believe it.
You know, I really can't believe it.
I want to thank everybody.
That cares 'cause no one really cared.
You know?
No one really cares
about what happens to
us out on the street.
They look at us like,
oh, there's this whores.
They're just out there
doing this and doing that.
But it's not that we go
through a lot, a whole lot.
And we only have each other to be family
we have real family, yeah,
but most of the time
they're not understanding to
what we go through out here.
So we depend on each other for
moral support and everything.
You know what I'm saying?
And like I said once again,
I want to thank everybody,
you know, for caring mostly, you know,
and I appreciate their
donations and everything.
And thank you Juliet, once again.
I'm really nervous right now
because this is just such a shock to me
but I wasn't expecting none of this.
- [Interviewer] I'm glad,
you look happy and healthy.
- [Ann] I've been trying,
I been sleeping a lot.
- [Interviewer] Last time you
looked much more stressed.
- [Ann] Well, yeah, yeah.
I was way way stressed as I
think that's why I'm afraid to
look at my own interview.
I haven't seen it.
I didn't know anything about the comments
- [Interviewer] Does
it keep you up at night
or anything like that?
- [Ann] A lot of times, you
know, I sleep periodically.
It's like, if I sit still
longer than a minute or two,
I'm asleep, you know,
'cause I really don't sleep well.
I have nightmares, you know,
sometimes it's hard for me.
I've went into this.
Like I've always had depression
thing, but I now it's like,
it's trying to overwhelm me and take
over and I'm really fighting it right now.
You know?
'Cause sometimes it's hard
for me to just open the door
and go outside, go across
the street to the store.
It's just really hard, you know?
And I'm dealing with it.
But I mean, maybe I don't
know I need counseling,
and you know, a little bit more help.
I'm not talking about financially.
I'm talking about mentally
and stuff like that.
Because this tends to take
a toll on you, you know.
- [Interviewer] You're very strong.
- [Ann] No I'm not.
- [Interviewer] Yeah you are.
- I don't think so, I go through a lot.
It takes a lot from me day to day
just to get up and do what I have to do.
I literally have to have drugs.
I mean, of course, marijuana, a drink
something to deal with the streets now.
I can't just--
- [Interviewer] I was
down there last night
and the night before and
I'm watching all these girls
and they have to be--
- On something.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- You have to be on
some kind of something.
- [Interviewer] But you have
to, you have to look your best.
You have to have the right attitude.
You have to be friendly and personable
and they're getting
rejected over and over again
even though they're beautiful women,
but they're getting
crapped on left and right.
And guy's just like--
- Right exactly because--
- [Interviewer] It's not like
every guy drives up to them
and says oh my God let me
give you a bunch of money,
let's hang out.
- Well I know one thing for sure,
I've been blessed in
a kind of certain way.
But to where it the last
few days just seemed
like it hasn't been so hard for me.
I haven't had to just be out there,
like all the time and deal
with different people.
'cause I've met a couple of friends that
for some reason they
just did it really nice
and helped me with my rent.
And we chill it's like
last night I watched the
world series baseball game
you know, Dodgers lost.
But you know it comes
with a friend and just
happened to meet me.
And they said that like my
personality and everything.
And so they helped me.
So last night was one
of the nights that I had a chance to rest.
- [Interviewer] That's nice.
- I had a chance to sleep all night.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Until about 10, 11
this morning, you know?
Yeah so I got pretty much
some rest last night.
But then again, then it's
like, when I wake up, okay,
I'm gonna be real, I'm like, okay.
I got rest now it's time to go outside.
I have to get into the
ora, and get dressed,
and try to feel sexy, you know,
so I can attract attention,
and hurry up and get what I got to get.
So I can go back in the house, you know?
So basically it's still up and down.
I was dealing with the
ocean fighting for the shore
and once I get close to it,
I'm still getting pushed back.
You know, nothing changed
about that, you know,
but I'm still begging on
myself to try to be strong.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] You're doing a great job.
You're doing a great job.
Thank you so much, I'm
trying, but I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Alright Ann,
thank you very much for coming in again
and good luck with everything.
- [Ann] Thank you so much.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.